bonjour à tous et merci d'être avec nous
pour ce nouveau numéro de dimanche en
politique sur france 3 bourgogne
la recomposition politique qui découle
de l'arrivée au pouvoir des manuels
macro et de la création de la république
en marche laisse les partis
traditionnels sonné depuis quelques mois
alors si les républicains viennent de se
trouver un nouveau chef la droite reste
plus divisé que jamais et à gauche la
situation est encore très confuse
comment la gauche peut-elle rebondir
pour exister
quelle ligne adoptée gauche de
gouvernement ou gauche de transformation
pragmatisme ou révolution entre macro et
mélenchon y at il un espace politique
pour un nouveau parti socialiste
et quel leader à sa tête france 3
bourgogne ouvre le débat ce dimanche
matin avec nos invités antoine hoareau
bonjour bonjour jean christophe vient
d'eux est premier secrétaire de la
section ps de dijon
merci d'être avec nous en ce dimanche
matin alexandre emorine bonjour vous
représentez dans ce débat à la france
insoumise on dit plus porte-parole 1
depuis quelques mois c'est ça depuis la
convention on a choisi de d'élargir au
maximum en tout cas les responsabilités
elle voulait pas de chef c'est ça pas
besoin je pense que les gens peuvent se
prendre en main il y en a qui prend
beaucoup de place ont marqué dans la
france a souri stade jean luc mélenchon
et beaucoup il ya 17 députés au total
c'est vrai on va y revenir dans un
instant merci à tous les deux d'avoir
accepté cette invitation pour débattre
vous qui nous regarde et vous pouvez
bien sûr commenter cette émission depuis
chez vous sur les réseaux sociaux avec
le hashtag dit mme paul bourgogne alors
pour débuter ce débat messieurs j'ai
envie de vous demander si ça n'est pas
un peu compliqué aujourd'hui d'être un
jeune militant ce que vous faites partie
des jeunes en politique jeune militant
de gauche aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas un peu désabusé antoine
hoareau désabusé n'ont par contre
convaincu qu'il faut continuer le combat
certainement pas ce que va être de
gauche aujourd'hui c'est lutter contre
un gouvernement qui supprime lisf parce
que c'est une mesure extrêmement injuste
quand on se rend compte qu un rentier
qui gagne 20 mille euros de son capital
par mois le pay 12 % d'impôt est qu un
salarié ou un fonctionnaire cas 1400
euros d'impôts par mois
by 14 % d'impôts il ya effectivement une
vraie injustice être de gauche c'est
défendre des emplois aidés c'est
défendre le logement social qui est mise
à mal aujourd'hui par ce gouvernement
donc c'est s'engager toujours pour
lutter contre les injustices et pour
défendre la justice sociale mais elle
joue gauche c'est aussi avoir vu son
corps
dara benoît hamon pour vous en
l'occurrence à 6% éliminé dès le premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle
effectivement mais c'est pas pour autant
qu'il faut se satisfaire de cette
situation un peu d a dit non mais être
déçu et découragé non c'est pas dans le
tempérament des gens de gauche vous
savez être de gauche c'est réfléchir
c'est ne jamais satisfaire des
injustices et donc c'est continuer à
avancer continuer à réfléchir
et donc c'est ce qu'on est en train de
faire en ce moment le parti socialiste
et on pourra en parler
alexandre emorine même question est-ce
que vous n'êtes pas un peu désabusés
parce que finalement vous fait de
l'obstruction vos députés dont vous
parliez font de l'obstruction à
l'assemblée nationale aux fonctions non
non non non ça ne mène finalement à rien
vous êtes entonné dans une opposition de
principe
de fait de toute façon pour l'instant
rien une majorité pléthorique pour en
marche après sur la question de qu'est
ce qu'être de gauche
j'irai même qu'est ce que c'est la
gauche au final est-ce que entre un jean
luc mélenchon et un françois rebsamen on
peut dire que c'est la même chose je
pense pas je pense que dans la tête des
gens c'est pas aussi clair que ça donc
si vous voulez nous regardent aussi un
petit peu pour nous je dirais le monde
qui nous entoure en fait on est
pragmatique aussi est notre objectif il
est de conquérir le pouvoir pas pour
conquérir le pouvoir en tant que tel et
pour transformer la société
donc je parlais tout à l'heure de gauche
de gouvernement ou de gauche de
transformation
c'est la même chose et nos s'inscrit
totalement là dedans on veut exercer des
responsabilités et on propose aussi du
coût d un projet qui en opposition
totale à sud emmanuel macron par exemple
élargir l'accès aux soins est pas fermé
des lits d'hôpitaux augmenter le vin ne
pas fermer deux services publics alors
que dans les campagnes dans certains
quartiers on voit que ça ferme et que
certaines personnes se retrouvent sans
une école un bureau de poste ou une
maison médicale à côté de chez eux
donc on a si vous voulez hein un projet
qui est en totale au prix sur les macro
bien entendu aujourd'hui à l'assemblée
nationale il est minoritaire
c'est clair à la majorité en marché est
très importante mais par contre je pense
que dans la société
on a en tout cas quoi qu'il arrive n'a
pas de majorité sociale pour emmanuel
macron et il y a de plus en plus de gens
qui se reconnaissent dans ce qu'on peut
porter parce qu'on part tout simplement
de leur quotidien
alors on va on va y venir à ses idées de
gauche dans la société à ce qu'elle y
soit ou pas vous n'avez pas réussi à
mobiliser sur la loi de ravages
d'ailleurs mais en tout cas social vous
utiliser ce terme là est ce qu emmanuel
macron quand même à un moment donné
réduit en miettes que la gauche sur
l'échiquier politique on en viendra à la
société ensuite mais surtout sur
l'échiquier politique non je le laisse
peu d'espacé mais aujourd'hui ce qu'il
faut c'est incarner une gauche crédible
position crédible une opposition de
gauche c'est formulé des propositions
s'est montré que dans l'action du
gouvernement il ya des injustices et
donc c'est ça c'est être crédible et on
le montre que tous les jours nous dans
les collectivités je vous rappelle que
le parti socialiste aujourd'hui c'est le
plus grand des deux réseaux d'élus
locaux en france dans les mairies dans
l'est dans les villages dans les villes
dans les métropoles dans les
départements dans les régions et tous
les jours on mène des politiques de
gauche quand on est à paris fit qu'à
sion sociale la tarification
proportionnelle aux revenus des familles
dans les cantines ce sont des mesures de
gauche à droite des exemples est ce que
la région est toujours dirigée par une
présidente de gauche elle s'appelle
marie-guite dufay
elle a soutenu emmanuel macron à
l'élection présidentielle est toujours
membre du parti socialiste à ma
connaissance mais est ce que pour vous
c'est toujours les socialistes qui
dirigent
on l'a vu que ça se déchire aussi au
sein même majorité un peu de la majorité
la majorité et a été élu sur un
programme et aujourd'hui elle applique
ce programme et c'est très bien quand à
la situation personnelle de marie-guite
dufay effectivement moi je souhaiterais
qu'il y ait une clarification quant à
son positionnement politique
ça arrive ça relève de la responsabilité
de la fédération socialiste du doubs
hélas ça ne relève pas d'autres
instances que de la fédération du doubs
mais oui il devrait y avoir des
clarifications de la part de marie-guite
dufay qui aujourd'hui je ne suis pas
tout à fait certain qu'elle ait encore
sa place au parti socialiste vous après
sa majorité la majorité socialiste
aujourd'hui au département quand par
exemple on parle de mobilité quand par
exemple on parle de développement
économique ou d'environnement les
mesures qui sont prises on crève de
gauche c'est évidemment parce que ça a
été c'est un programme et le plan de
mandat est un plan derrière moi j'aurai
la majorité de marie-guite dufay
elle vous semble encore à gauche à la
région c'est qu'elle n'est jamais assez
à ghoulam a joué la majorité
diverses à la région en tout cas marqué
dufay est sorti du champ de la gauche
appartient moment la suite my mind à
cran et son projet e par contre bon moi
ça me fait un petit peu sourire quand
j'entends le parti socialiste dire qu'il
incarne une opposition etc
il me semble qu'il ya des membres du
parti socialiste qui sont aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui gouvernement ne sont pas
exclues en va et vient pas du tout jean
yves le drian a toujours sa carte
non non il a toujours accusé d'ailleurs
la question de la reprendre
éventuellement l'an prochain il a
déclaré il ya deux jours au livre
olivier emmanuel macron et qui quelques
jours après entre gouvernements et les
deux boucheries n'est pas de gauche vous
savez les ambitions individuelles qui ne
portent pas de projets collectifs n'ont
jamais mené à grand chose emmanuel
macron il a fait un petit peu du sarkozy
le drh de la république et les rh de la
gauche comme en 2007 mais on a vu
l'avenir politique d'un bernard kouchner
ou de l'ancien maire de besançon doubs
j'ai même oublié le nom donc franchement
c'est pas voilà c'est ses désirs des
aventures individuelles et c'est pas ça
qui crée de la critique vous vous dites
aujourd'hui olivier du soft il
il a voté contre le budget une semaine
après il le défend des séoud la
crédibilité du discours politique dans
ce cas là elle est où la crédibilité cdc
des comportements et c'est le fait
qu'ils sont intenables pour est ce que
c'était les salles sont pour la majorité
des manuels mac rondes de police à vous
laisser l'espace politique à suivre
c'est pour essayer de déstabiliser les
partis de gouvernement qui pourrait
incarner une opposition évidemment mais
ça ne reste que des hadrons des
aventures individuelles le parti
socialiste je pense aujourd'hui ne peut
pas être être une force d'opposition
crédible à partir du moment où comme je
disais des gens du parti socialiste au
gouvernement et en même temps il a
ouvert la voie pendant cinq ans au la
politique d' emmanuel macron quand on
prend les différentes voies travail la
loi elle comme briand 2016 la loi macron
avant la loi rebsamen juste avant sa
ouvert la voie à l'arrière un crime
d'activer jours du carême qui a permis
aujourd'hui au taux de pauvreté de
baisser en france pour la première fois
et que j aie qui a aussi produit
d'activités situation a mis aux chômeurs
en plus entre 2002 et 2010 non c'est pas
vrai taux de chômage est resté mais on
n'a jamais aujourd'hui en france et bien
d'autres sans croissance c'est quand
même c'est complètement fou et une
réalité à partir du moment où emmanuel
macron s'attaque aux plus démunis
notamment en baissant les apl comme ça a
été dit on peut faire aussi un parallèle
françois hollande lorsqu'il augmente la
tva en 2012 et s'attaque aussi aux plus
démunis le sénat paul plus injuste quand
vous avez 400 l'état l'état qui baissent
les dotations ctivité loyal au bout de
12 milliards entre 2014 et 2017
ça baisse aussi la seule à la capacité
des collectivités locales à développer
les solidarités sur les parce que la
situation de 2009 n'était pas la
situation dans laquelle on est au jour
et en 2000 ça c'est ce même argument
qu'elle avait à la situation mais ça
touche à la préparer le chemin emmanuel
macron bien je n'entends pas je crois
que la politique de françois hollande
est une politique de gauche on l'a vu
avec le tir payant généralisé
on l'a vu avec la prime d'activité on
l'a vu avec le compte personnel
d'activité on l'a vu avec ces mesures
qui ont été prises qui sont des mesures
de gauche
oui il ya eu une période d'une politique
de l'offre qui a été fait parce que la
gauche c'est une gauche qui est
pragmatique donc c'est à dire qu'elle
s'adapte à la réalité et c'est bien la
différence aussi entre une gauche plus
contestataire et une gauche de
gouvernement
c'est qu'à un moment on est en capacité
de pouvoir prendre des mesures réelles
réaliste dans la situation dans laquelle
vous y retrouver la france en 2012 avait
parlé tous les deux de françois rebsamen
on va en dire un mot
le maire de dijon françois rebsamen lui
a été ambiguë
aussi pendant la campagne de l'élection
présidentielle royal en disant oui
officiellement loyal mais en fait il a
toujours laissé entendre qu'il était un
peu mac compatible par moment qu'il
était noir en désaccord avec la brigade
il a apporté son parrainage à benoît
hamon moi j'ai fait on a organisé des
meetings à dijon pour soutenir benoît
hamon françois rebsamen avait tourné des
vidéos qui ont été diffusés dans ses
meetings pour soutenir le candidat du
parti socialiste parce que françois
rebsamen est un socialiste
il le démontre tous les jours dans les
politiques municipales qui sont menées à
dijon c'est avec les quelques problèmes
alors avec 5 janvier les gens qui sont
partis oui c'est parce que la majorité
elle était réputée parce que la majorité
au conseil municipal c'est une majorité
qui rassemble françois rebsamen c'est
quelqu'un qui rassemble donc oui il ya
des personnes qui sont qui était au
parti radical aujourd'hui je dois jouer
au modèle socialiste au premier plan on
allait il joue un rôle au premier plan
il est président de la fédération
nationale des élus socialistes et rim
est plus là et il joue juste que c'est
un renouvellement important et françois
rebsamen évidemment un avis important
pour le parti socialiste alexandre
marine et j'entendais tout à l'heure une
demande de clarification par rapport à
marie-guite dufay puisqu'elle a soutenu
emmanuel macron j'invite chacun à
regarder chercher sur internet une
tribune publiée dans le jdd
eh ben le 9 avril 2007 de françoise elle
s'amène tout à fait qu'ils appellent à
voter maintenant parce qu'il est je cite
le site en capacité de rassembler les
progressistes des deux bords on peut
penser que ce texte pendant donc c'est
moi c'est un soutien clair il appelle à
former une majorité margueray il appelle
à reporter à former une majorité de
progrès il savait pas exactement le
projet de manuel macron qui était sorti
avant elle m'était savait ce qu'elle
jamais vraiment eu de projet le sondage
annuel à une majorité de progrès et qui
n'est pas du tout un appel à voter en
faveur si on est contre son projet c'est
bien car c'est pas du tout la même chose
il n'a pas appelé à la retenue
il ya eu un événement cette semaine
comme comme vous l'avez sûrement suivi
en politique c'est le retour de françois
hollande
première grande interview depuis son
départ de l'elysée il était l'invité
chez nos confrères de rtl il a déclaré
notamment j'aimerais vous faire réagir à
cette phrase le parti socialiste s'il
veut être une force du gouvernement a un
avenir parce que la social démocratie
européenne a un avenir
je vais demander d'abord alexandre
emorine de réagir
françois hollande a le droit d'exprimer
un avis bien entendu comme comme tous
les français par contre je pense qu'ils
devraient être peut-être un peu plus
discret un peu plus humble puisqu'à
chaque fois qu'il prend la parole on
l'avait déjà vu au mois d'avril moment
du dernier mois avant l'élection et
encore maintenant il prend la parole
pour taper sur jean luc mélenchon et la
france insoumise et pour être quand même
l'a dit un assez bienveillant avec
emmanuel macron au bout de six mois il
attend toujours de voir un petit peu
wasquehal quinquennat va aller il me
semble que ça ça pose parce qu'un
problème mais comme je le disais tout à
l'heure à partir du moment où il a
ouvert la voie c'est aussi tout à fait
logique à françois on n'est pas très
sympathique et jean luc mélenchon jean
luc mélenchon n'a jamais été très
sympathique avec françois hollande
maintien des accords politiques mais
bien avec ça je voulais dire c'est que
voilà il est bien entendu en désaccord
politique avec jean luc mélenchon pas
tellement avec emmanuel macron quant à
l'avenir de la social démocratie
européenne je pense et françaises
d'ailleurs je pense qu'il n'y en a plus
en fait c'est un certain moment le
moment social démocrate est passé sept
heures
c'était le moment du compromis social
démocrate pendant pendant les trente
glorieuses aujourd'hui il faut assumer
un rapport de force peu après la même
mais il faut aussi mais aujourd'hui un
rapport de force non s'affrontent avec
le matin avant leur union européenne onu
n'auront pas ingrat obligé de toute
façon d'avoir un rapport au neuf ans on
ne construira dans le rapport de force
la preuve c'est l'échec de la
mobilisation sur la loi travail sur les
ordonnances du travail de manon jean luc
mélenchon a voulu faire un rapport de
force en appelant des millions de
personnes à manifester dans la rue il ya
eu cent mille personnes qui se sont
déplacées et ça a renforcé la version
puisque là elle à avoir des millions de
personnes a été fait et comment le jouer
ça même divisée l'action syndicale ça a
même divisée d'action syndicale et au
final ça a renforcé l'action du
gouvernement qu'elle fût qui a dit à vue
qui a pu déplacer ces qui a pu ne pas
passer ces ordonnances obs mars pourrait
être un rouge à lèvres ou la gauche
aujourd'hui à françois hollande écouter
il a des avis et un ancien président de
la république
il a un nouveau statut qui donne des
avis sur la situation politique
effectivement il a pris la parole pour
dénoncer la suppression des emplois
aidés je pense que l'un comme l'autre on
peut être d'accord pour dénoncer la
suppression des emplois aidés mais ces
contrôles en passant le mans prend la
parole pour ça c'est très bien après de
là à y rester un peu ambigu et ses
sculptures et de là mais de là à être de
nouveau candidat à une élection il n'y
aura pas supplémentaire et je pense que
la leçon de retour manqué de nicolas
sarkozy ces dernières années ça doit
être quelques choix doit servir à tout
même à briser défendre le parti
socialiste michel sapin qui disait ça
cette semaine il a mis en garde contre
le syndrome sarkozy a bien fait vous
feriez la même chose sur l'ex ans et
maureen j'ai pas de leçon à donner à
françois hollande s'il revient j'ai
envie de dire tant mieux pour nous mais
au-delà de ça vous savez je crois que je
crois hélas notre démocratie aujourd'hui
elle est en train d'évoluer
hélas on se dirige plus vers un système
presque à l'américaine où quand on a
perdu les élections qu'on n'a pas été en
capacité de se représenter
et bien évidemment derrière on ne peut
plus revenir comme ça pouvait être le
cas
comme chirac l'a fait par exemple en se
présentant trois fois et en arrivant que
la dernière donc on est dans un temps
différent aujourd'hui
moi je tenais à revenir sur la question
de la mobilisation complète votre
travail allait alors vive et c'est très
bien me dire que nous sommes et
responsable un petit peu d'une division
etc
mais je pense qu'il faut que ces gens
responsables le biais ça ils savent
passer pendant les cinq dernières années
vous avez ce mais au final peut-être qui
est le pire poison démocratique dire la
résignation la résignation chez les gens
dire qu'ils ne sont plus en capacité de
se dire ensemble on peut gagner et ça
c'est terrible à l'effet 49,3 s'était
montrée par énormément d'études vous
voyagez pas que leur gouvernement
alex a le droit aussi avec vos idées et
le talent de jean luc mélenchon arriver
à mobiliser aujourd'hui ni les syndicats
ni le parti socialiste ni la france
insoumise sur cette affaire de la
mobilisation contre la nouvelle loi
travail n'avait réussi à mobiliser or là
il y avait un espace politique pour le
faire
vous auriez pu ça n'a pas fonctionné
c'est ce que laissait 50 a réussi à
mobiliser
savez comme moi que c'est très compliqué
aussi de se mobiliser en semaine parce
qu'il ya eu énormément d'appels à la
mobilisation qui ont été faits en
sommeil puis il devrait même hacker
croll un jeu plutôt que de s'allier avec
les syndicats que vous avez en plus
faire une manifestation supplémentaire
nous qu'on a fait on a convoqué donc une
manifestation politique
le samedi en complément des syndicats et
pas les brouiller les cartes
pas du tout parce que ce jour là si
j'avais envie de reprendre les mots de
sens vraiment mais jean-luc mélenchon
sur le coup ça a été un petit peu
l'opposant utile au gouvernement je
pense alors ça c'est dommage de parler
comme la droite et le front national et
non c'est pas les exagérant la même
chose c'est par contre jean-luc mélange
alliant sport sont fermement tout en
tics j'aimerais bien pouvoir intéressant
dans jean luc mélenchon dans son
discours le 23 septembre
qu'est ce qu'il dit il dit aux syndicats
marchait devant on vous suit on est là
pour vous aider
je vois pas où est la division là dedans
bassi parce que du café des rendez vous
supplémentaire
et vous savez aujourd'hui entre edouard
philippe darmanin et puis madame garrido
madame aubenas
je crois vraiment qu'il ya un espace
pour une autre gauche une gauche de
conviction c'est à dire une gauche qui
une bouche qui est prête à gouverner
c'est quoi la gauche de rideau la gauche
au bono la gauche de jean-luc mélenchon
et puis le gouvernement de droite
actuellement entre le parti unique
importé par la république en marche les
votes à main levée
etc et puis de l'autre côté les victimes
de la mode qui croient que c'est en
enlevant les cravates que on va défendre
mieux des ouvriers il ya effectivement
une vraie visite à niveau de cravates
aujourd'hui donc effectivement mais en
l'occurrence n'est pas l'assemblée
nationale n'ont pas été publiés il ya
vraiment une place et une vraie place
pour porter une gauche crédible c'est à
dire qui est en capacité de pouvoir
répondre réellement aux problématiques
des français et on le voit dans les
collectivités je reviens toujours au
terrain parce que c'est là que c'est
important mais dans les collectivités
aujourd'hui on mène des politiques de
gauche quand on crée des places en
crèche
quand on défend le logement social quand
on construit des logements à dijon c'est
dix sept mille logements qui ont été
construits pour répondre aux besoins
réels de la population
quand on rénove des écoles c'est ça
aussi la gauche prize est d'accord avec
ces politiques locales au cas par cas
par moments vous dites avec vos anciens
amis communistes qui parfois sont dans
des majorités de gauche dans les
collectivités locales
on peut faire les choses ensemble c'est
à leur appréciation moi ce que je
remarque c'est que on peut vanter le
bilan de françois rebsamen chose comme
ça il ya une certaine opacité qui est
fait et ça ça participe aussi d'une
ancienne manière de pratiquer la
politique est de faire la politique doit
patienter bien entendu par exemple vous
avez les contrats les contrats sur l'eau
sur la distribution de l'eau sur la
question de la métropole à dijon enfin
10 en métropole mon genou ces contrats
sont selon la loi public chaque citoyen
a le droit de les consulter
aujourd'hui il faut que les citoyens qui
demandent ces contrats saisissent
l'autorité administrative
la cada pour les avoir parce que la
mairie ne veut pas les donner pourquoi
une telle opacité
ça c'est une vieille manière de faire de
la politique on pratique et on la fait
pas à vous rapprocher d'un emmanuel
macron quand vous parlez commencer ainsi
un monde que vous critiquez bien entendu
c'est toujours des vieilles pratiques
vous savez nous on est là pour faire de
la politique avec les citoyens etc les
citoyens eux-mêmes kid qui doivent le
parti socialiste regarde regarder les
pratiques actuellement on est en plein
débat budgétaire à la mairie de dijon le
débat le budget devrait être adopté
demain soir il vient d'avoir des
réunions publiques dans tous les
quartiers où les élus vont à la
rencontre des citoyens pour construire
le budget avait que moi j'avais yann la
démocratie participative avait une vraie
que vraie question là dessus est ce que
vous pensez que faire de la politique
avec les citoyens c'est les voir quatre
fois dans l'année le dernier mois nan
c'est pour ça que les bonnes années il
ya à ce que vous les commissions de
quartier il ya des ressources il ya des
gens qui sont venus une fois par
trimestre également des recettes par
touriste a dit son quartier par contre
vous allez quand une difficilement
arrive à me faire croire que la question
budgétaire vous la règle et autour des
suites aux réunions avec les habitants
autour du 15 du quart des six passages
en premier lieu au mois de septembre
par exemple il ya une vraie
questionnaire la charité publique
regardez il ya une vraie question sur la
tranquillité publique aujourd'hui il ya
des soucis dans un certain nombre de
quartiers
donc il ya une politique qui est menée
on va recruter 30 policiers municipaux
cette année et on a obtenu du
gouvernement 28 policiers nationaux
supplémentaires mais il y avait une
question est ce qu'on n'embauche plus et
ben ali a été débattue cette question
avec les habitants est ce que on
augmente les impôts pour pouvoir
embaucher des policiers au million ou
avec les rappeurs faire un débat sur
l'agglomération dijonnaise et ça s'est
passé
oui c'est la vie quotidienne et puis
c'est la réalité aussi de l'année
station des vosges dans la spécialiste
de ce type est un petit peu de toute
responsabilité nationale à se recentrer
sur sa parole et on a d'amour et on a
démontré tout de suite à l'instant que
l'on pouvait avoir aussi un débat
national
mais que la crédibilité de l'action et
se fait aussi la réalité on en vient à
la crise au ps et à l'avenir du parti
socialiste je me tourne vers antoine
hoareau mais j'ai envie aussi d'entendre
alexandre emorine sur cette question la
crise a tout de même fait naître alors
défaut qualité à une nouvelle bande de
khadra avec des personnalités olivier
faure jean françois ii bat boris vallot
matthias fekl najat vallaud belkacem
est-ce que l'avenir du parti socialiste
peut s'incarner dans ces personnes là il
ya deux choses sur l'avenir il ya la
question des personnes évidemment mais
il ya aussi la question de la ligne
alors on va parler de la ligne dans un
instant on est deux secondes et demie
sur les personnes mais sur les personnes
je crois que les personnes doivent
incarner un projet elle doivent incarner
une ligne et donc c'est d'abord se poser
la question de la ligne politique pour
ensuite voir qu'il incarne évidemment il
ya des cadres à mais il ya aussi qui
sont pour la plupart des anciens membres
du gouvernement ou des anciens
responsables de la majorité de la
majorité sortante
vous n'avez pas cité stéphane le foll
mais qui peut aussi faire partie soit
cette nouvelle phase qui doit être
carcasse pour ça je dois citer ça doit
être ça mais je sais c'est une
génération qui eux qui fait partie des
candidats potentiels à la délinquance et
du parti socialiste sont des candidats
qui sont effectivement tout à fait
crédible mais encore une fois c'est pas
la question de la personne
même si le projet doit être incarnée à
un moment ou un autre effectivement par
une personnalité il faut déjà se poser
la question de la ligne et sur la ligne
le parti socialiste ce qu'il faut c'est
qu'ils soient crédibles sur le plan
économique qui doit mettre la justice
sociale la lutte contre les inégalités
au coeur de ses priorités
et puis surtout il doit être sur la
construction européenne la construction
européenne c'est quelque chose qu'on
défend et qu'on extrait voilà qu'à
l'instruction différente avec différents
sur les peines etc sans bride et avec la
france insoumise la construction
européenne c'est quelque chose qu'on
veut des formes parce que la france elle
a un rôle majeur à jouer en cette
période notamment avec le break site et
donc on a vraiment un rôle important à
avoir sur la question européenne
et puis doit y avoir une volonté de
régulation une volonté de régulation au
niveau du monde et la question
écologique
c'est une vraie volonté politique de
régulation des enjeux du monde qui ont
pour la lire cette ligne là pour
incarner la ligne mais j'ai pas de
préférence particulière
je pense que najat vallaud-belkacem
comme stéphane le foll sont des
personnes de talent et c'est tant mieux
qu'au parti socialiste on est des
personnes de talent qu'il le démontre
tous les jours donc la question de la
personne viendra dans un deuxième temps
mais c'est d'abord la question de la
ligne est-ce que c'était une erreur de
choisir benoît hamon comme candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
venant à manquer dont le mouvement
génération avec un point et un ace
est en train de se structurer d'ailleurs
dans la région tout à fait mais c'est
bien qu' une diversité dans la gauche à
la gauche elle a toujours été diverses
oui mais trop éclatée oui savez bien
comment mais ils savent que j'aime trop
éclatée pour réunir pour une majorité
c'est moi j'ai accompli mais sauf que
j'espère qu'à un moment tout le monde
aura là le sens des responsabilités pour
aller vers l'union parce que c'est
l'union de la gauche qui fait gagner la
gauche et ça a toujours été le cas dans
l'histoire c'est de voir l'union c'est
une avancée jose ramon je dirais pas que
c'est un mauvais choix est d'ailleurs le
problématique des primaires c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les deux candidats du
deuxième tour y en a plus aucun qui au
parti socialiste donc c'est quand même
qu'il doit y avoir aussi un problème lié
au mode de désignation
il a été désigné par une prière ouvert
vous arriviez même pas à la faire entre
vous c'est l'unité de nous aider j'en ai
plein c'est vrai c'est un problème de
ligne parce que je pense qu'avec benoît
hamon et même même ensemble avec la
france insoumise heureusement il ya
beaucoup plus de choses qui nous
rassemble que de choses qui nous divise
il ya des jeux centrale qui nous dit oui
il ya des choses qui ne dit mot sur
l'europe mais il ya quand même sur la
stratégie européenne mais par exemple je
suis persuadé que dans des majorités
locales
on serait tout à fait en capacité de
pouvoir travailler ensemble et je
l'espère d'ailleurs j'espère qu'on aura
le sens des responsabilités pour ça
allait la bataille de la présidentielle
pour terminer un mot il faut pas se
tromper d'adversaire mais j'ai pas
d'adversaire à gauche à gauche on peut
avoir des divergences mais mon
adversaire c'est la droite et l'extrême
droite ce soit vos adversaires c'est la
question
alors là ça c'est noté chine d'appliquer
l'accord lors de l'élection
présidentielle on avait depuis 19 ans
yvon enregistré entre benoît hamon et
jean luc mélenchon ça n'a pas fonctionné
en rocade s'est retiré au profit de
l'autre résultat personne au second tour
de l'élection quand on parle pas refaire
l'histoire mais aussi des divergences
mais des personnalités qui méritent mais
c'est sur du fond parce qu'en même temps
par aussi du principe que c'est pas en
accumulant les logos vous savez en bas
d'une affiche en sonatrach qu'on
arrivera à mobiliser sur un projet axé
sur un projet notamment sur la question
éthique et la gauche qui se dit que le
parti socialiste is divise et vous avec
vos amis communistes par exemple
l'ancien front de gauche invite vous
paraît le front de gauche c'est une
stratégie on avait estimé peut-être
qu'une époque justement voilà le cartel
d'organisations de différents logos et
est la manière la plus efficace
d'arriver à prendre le pouvoir
force est de constater que ça a été
échec sur échec après 2012 qu'on a dit
voilà changement de stratégie la france
a soumis ce qui je le rappelle est un
mouvement citoyen où chacun peut entrer
sans cotisations etc etc modifie aussi
échange les manières de pratiquer la
politique
on y vient comme on peut comme on veut
il n'y a aucune
aucune obligation d'engagement nous si
vous voulez on se base aussi sur le
quotidien des gens
on porte aussi ces choses là vous
parlais tout à l'heure un petit peu de
folklore
moi je pense à françois ruffin à
l'assemblée nationale qui est venu avec
ce maillot de foot oui aux gens reconnus
on se sont arrêtés sur le malien à
l'assemblée nationale sa part
l'ambassadrice parler des bénévoles dans
les associations les bénévoles dans les
assauts lycée de la communication
alexandre les moai nommé c'est sûr qu'il
faut communiquer autour des séances il a
new show comédie lixiviation j'aimerais
juste et j'aimerais la communication
c'est important aussi pour faire passer
ses idées quand vous allez dans les
associations aujourd'hui
et justement ces bénévoles ces fameux
ces fameuses personne qui vend du club
de foot pli les maillots pour que les
gamins puissent aller jouer le week end
et bien quand on leur dira vous avez vu
ce qu'a dit rufin à 10 points ça nous a
touchés et des gens qui ont eu des
larmes aux yeux parce qu'ils envoient
leurs gamins comme ça donc
mais peut-être que des gens ont retenu
le maillot de foot non moi ça a permis
de parler de cette question là je vois
qu'avant ça ne se faisait pas qu'on
avance un mot sur jean luc mélenchon est
ce que c'est le seul opposant de gauche
aujourd'hui est ce qu'il incarne
l'opposition de gauche seul c'est votre
seul je sais pas en tout cas premier ep
plus crédible ça c est ce qu il porte un
projet clair et en opposition qui est
sans ambiguïté contrairement aux autres
passagers le seul certainement pas c'est
je disais tout à l'heure c'était
l'opposant utile je pense que c'est le
cas et je voudrais vraiment s'il arrive
à la fin d'un mot aujourd'hui les
premiers opposants gouvernement sur les
mers ce sont les maires dans tous les
villages dans toutes les villes dans
toutes les métropoles de france c'est
aujourd'hui l'opposition au gouvernement
c'est les maires et justement on n'est
plus dans une histoire d'étiquettes
parce que là on est devant on a dit
s'exprimer
il ya une vraie inquiétude donc
aujourd'hui non jean luc mélenchon est
loin d'être le seul d'opposants et
d'ailleurs mais j'en suis un aussi et je
ne suis pas avec jean-luc alors comment
faire gagner la gauche
selon vous rapidement et bientôt
alexandrine faire gagner la gauche
6-6 et faire gagner des étiquettes
honnêtement je ne sais pas si c'est très
utile par contre je pense que c'est
important de faire gagner le peuple
aujourd'hui on est dans un dans un
moment où la division ne s'était plus
spécialement entre la gauche et la
droite ya plein de gens qui ne se
reconnaissent pas dans ces étiquettes là
notamment des gens qui ne votent plus
suite au dernier quinquennat
donc si vous voulez l'intérêt il est de
mener des politiques qui soient
réellement ambitieuse pour l'intérêt
général de faire des réformes qui soit
pour le plus grand nombre
mener la transition écologique pour
arrêter d'essayer de détruire la planète
pardon face à une oligarchie qui au
final ne pense qu'aux profits il faut il
faut être clair les lie à un point
d'accord entre alliés
je pense moi je ne pense pas parce que
l'écologie
qu'est-ce qu'on est derrière aussi
est-ce que 50% nucléaire c'est bien bon
je pense qu'on pourrait arriver aussi
aux 100 % d'énergies renouvelables parce
que le nucléaire s'il est dangereux à
100%
il est dangereux à 50 par l'état
peut-être c'est bien mais c'est pas
n'appuie pas sur un bouton s'est alors
fait aujourd'hui déjà il ya deux choses
il a la crédibilité par l'action et ça
on ne démontre tous les jours dans les
collectivités locales
et après il a apporté des solutions au
grand défi pour moi et je vois qu'il ya
cinq six grands défis il ya le défi
écologique on en a parlé c'est comment
est-ce qu'on lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
il ya le défi de l'heure on a peu
débattu de l'europe mais on vous n'aurez
inviterez pour qu'on le fasse sur ce il
ya le défi de l'europe et à la lutte
contre les inégalités
il ya le défi de la laïcité qui pourrait
aussi faire l'objet d'un débat parce que
pour le coup il ya un vrai sujet sur la
laïcité on y est le défi les démocrates
et bien tu es bon bah oui mais moi aussi
je pense en plus qu'on a décodé position
relativement commune sur la laïcité la
lecture de la loi 19 scène c'est pareil
on pourrait comme cela et puis il ya des
filles dans leur part au graphique
devrait quand même qu'on ait un mot
là-dessus il ya défi démographique le
vieillissement de la population en
france est l'enjeu majeur des 30
prochaines années personne n'en parle
aujourd'hui donc par exemple demain au
département vous avez des élus de gauche
qui vont aller défendre des politiques
contre la droite pour défendre les pour
défendre les personnes âgées et des
francs l'adaptation de la société au
vieillissement parce qu'il ya un vrai
sujet et nous cayron qu'il ya une
trentaine d'années c'est quelque chose
qu'on doit prendre à bras le corps parce
que dans 20 ans on a un tiers de la
population qui aura plus de 4 carats +60
info vous réconciliera pas tout de suite
mais peut-être que la gauche plurielle
reviendra un jour qui sait pour faire
gagner la gauche merci à tous les deux
d'avoir accepté de débattre ce matin et
deux à vous de nous avoir suivis dans un
instant le point sur l'actualité
régionale avec sébastien kérou puis la
partie nationale de dimanche en
politique ça va vous intéresser puisque
francis letellier reçoit un ancien
socialiste christophe castaner déléguée
générale de la république en marche et
secrétaire d'état aux relations avec le
parlement bon dimanche à tous sur france
3 tout simple